born and raised in boko haram camps
these children are experiencing for the
first time what it means to be a child
they're part of the 6 000 victims and
family members of boko haram fighters
who've surrendered to nigerian security
forces in the past few months
after a few weeks of psychological
support
those helping them are surprised by the
rapid transformation they see you see a
lot of them coming into the safe space
looking very distressed looking angry
but after weeks of engagement or because
we engage them for three months
sometimes depending on how we see their
vulnerability and all of that so we
after the engagement you see a lot of
changes you see them interacting better
you see them taking leadership roles you
see them doing so much better
for these children born and raised in
boko haram camps where toys are
forbidden
this moment of fun is a welcome change
many children here in the northeast they
were born into this conflict they have
never known a life that is outside of
conflict there are children born into
displaced camps and and for them this is
normal
this is not normal
social workers warn that it's a
difficult process
some they say may never know the joy of
childhood
only a small fraction of the over 5
million children affected by the boko
haram conflict have received any form of
psychological or social support the rest
are left to struggle on their own
experts wonder unless these children
receive the help they need now
the northeast and indeed nigeria could
be facing a bigger crisis when these
children grow up
with nearly a million children out of
school in nigeria's northeast most of
them in borno state there are concerns
they may be targeted for recruitment by
armed groups
if it's not that the impact will be
very big because these are children of 5
15 17 years adolescents and
they need to go back to school they need
to integrate their bond with their
family and friends integrate them with
other social activities
aid workers say time is running out for
hundreds of thousands of children and
this they say could be the reality
facing communities in nigeria's
northeast while boko haram still
continues to launch its attacks
al jazeera maiduguri nigeria